oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview notre invité
cette semaine est installé dans son
bureau à paris au sénat exactement à
l'abri des risques liés aux qu'ovide
notre invité cette semaine c'est bruno
retailleau sénateur de vendée président
du groupe plr au sénat
c'est l'ex groupe ump bonjour bruno
retailleau merci de nous recevoir ainsi
chez vous et dans ces conditions qui
sont peut-être pas très confortable mais
qui nous sont obligés que nous sommes
obligés de respecter très présent dans
les médias puisque et ça n'est un secret
pour personne
vous militez pour que l air organise des
primaires afin de désigner le candidat
qui sera investi par ce parti pour les
présidentielles de 2022
c'est d'ailleurs ce que vous avez dit un
à vos collègues du groupe pour essayer
de les convaincre d'organiser un
processus de sélection est ce que je me
trompe
et quels sont les résultats de cette de
cette conciliation
bonjour jean marc sylvestre et merci de
me recevoir cet après midi je vais
répondre à votre question c'était hier
le bureau politique de l air et je
voulais les convaincre que il ne fallait
pas rejeter la primaire pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux la primeur évoque de
mauvais souvenirs parce que qu'on a
perdu l'élection présidentielle et qu'il
y avait eu une primaire certains font un
raccourci mais kate info raccourci qui
considère que la cause de l'échec aux
présidentielles c'est la première
évidemment non la primaire a été un très
grand succès et si françois fillon a
fait dans les conditions que l'on sait
avec une campagne absolument impossible
au premier tour 20 % c'est parce qu'il y
avait cet élan de la primaire comme par
ailleurs cette fois ci on voit bien
qu'il ya pas de candidat naturel de
candidat providentiel qui se dégage il
faut un moment ou un autre un processus
qu'on appelle un processus de sélection
un processus de départage et je ne vois
pas d'autre méthode que la méthode
démocratique c'est à dire donner la
parole à nos militants donner la parole
à nos sympathisants pour que eux mêmes
reconnaissent leur champion ceux qui
porteront ce qui portera pardon le mieux
un projet mais aussi nos valeurs nos
propres valeurs
je pense qu'ils ont été assez sensible
en tout cas ce qui en est sorti à
l'ancien compromis donc dans un
compromis c'est une sorte de moyenne on
a indiqué qu'il y avait seulement deux
hypothèses ou bien dans les prochains
mois il ya un candidat naturel qui
s'impose
et là il n'y a pas besoin de faire de
prix mais évidemment en revanche si on
est dans l'autre hypothèse où aucun
candidat ne s'impose n'était évident
alors il faudra en octobre prochain
ce processus de sélection une primaire
et ce qui a été décidé c'est que le la
partie préparatoire devait très
rapidement avoir lieu donc ça veut dire
que quand gérard larcher est par exemple
le président du sénat au christian jacob
quel président de du groupe disent ne
pas vouloir de primaire ça veut dire
qu'il se situe plutôt dans la deuxième
hypothèse qu'ils acceptent le compromis
mais il se situe plutôt dans la deuxième
hypothèse dans le deuxième scénario
ils sont dans deux cas différente parce
que gérard larcher en fait tu veux une
primaire il indique que lui veut une
méthode d partagent donc la méthode de
départage c'est un autre mot c'est le
synonyme qui veut dire primaire donc
gérard h et si j'ose dire est dans le
camp de ceux qui souhaitent ce processus
là en revanche christian jacob aimerait
pouvoir disposer d'un candidat un peu
providentiel un candidat qui soit un
candidat naturel soit il advient soit il
ya cet événement soit il ne vient pas et
il faudra donc faire le choix par ce
processus électoral alors ya quand même
un problème majeur c'est que pas quand
il ya des candidats qui paraissent
crédibles ou qu'ils pensent être
crédible faut une démarche solidaire
solitaire je pense à xavier bertrand
je pense à valérie pécresse dans ce cas
là la primaire pour eux
ben ils ne veulent pas en entendre
parler et ils iront seul alors là aussi
il ya deux cas très différents
valérie pécresse a déclaré d'ailleurs ce
matin et mais elle l'a dit depuis des
mois et des mois qu'elle était favorable
un processus
primaires ouvertes comme moi parce que
je considère que si il ya des primaires
ouvertes c'est à dire que non seulement
pourraient voter des adhérents c'est à
dire des militants mais pourrait aussi
voter des sympathisants à la condition
qu'il accepte un certain nombre de
contraintes
eh bien il peut y avoir à ce moment là
des candidats aient l'air et des
candidats qui ne soit pas encarté diaby
à bertrand lui pour l'instant les
refusent
moi je pense et je milite pour que la
primaire soit très ouverte qu'elle
s'adresse non seulement à nos propres
militants à l'intérieur de heller mais
quelle qu'elles débordent
voilà pour les sympathisants parce que
je considère que ce sera difficile pour
un candidat à la présidentielle dans un
premier temps ci il doit refuser ce mode
de sélection démocratique je crois que
celui ou celle qui refuseraient de se
soumet de soumettre sa candidature au
vote d'un grand nombre de français de
droite un militant mais aussi
sympathisants je pense qu'il se
marginalise ray donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai toujours milité non
pas pour des primaires fermées
uniquement réservé à nos militants mais
aussi pour des vraies primaires ouvertes
pour que ça puisse nous donner un élan
un élan collectif et aussi pour qu'on
puisse parler des idées des projets
s'avérer pénible
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de trouver le
moyen de rassembler la droite dont une
partie d'ailleurs
c'est en aller du côté de manuel macro
dernière présidentielle
absolument vous avez raison et je
considère aussi que la primaire c'est la
seule façon de parler des idées c'est la
seule façon de parler du projet parce
que les idées les projets ça doit
s'incarner et sans primaires il n'y aura
pas vraiment de débat sur le fond alors
tout ça signifie bien sûr que vous serez
candidat pour être candidat à la
primaire j'imagine enfin bruno
retailleau c'est quasiment officiel
maintenant
ben écoute et cylia s'il ya une primaire
évidemment après avoir voulu une
primaire ça serait compliqué pour moi de
ne pas y aller alors vous comprenez bien
que toutes ces manoeuvres la politique
n'intéresse pas beaucoup
l'électorat ce qui intéresse les
électorats c'est plutôt l'analyse
critique que vous pourriez faire du
quinquennat qui qui est en train de se
terminer et surtout le projet que vous
pourriez offrir aux prochaines
présidentielles alors un mot sur le
discours critique que vous pourriez
faire à l'encontre de l'équipe de
l'exécutif actuel quel est le problème
que vous avez vous homme de droite
modérée face à la gestion macro le
problème c'est que mails macro aura
trahi ses deux promesses souvenez-vous
les deux grands engagements
c'était de réconcilier entre les
français et c'est est de transformer la
france
il n'aura pas réconcilier les français
parce que la france n'aura jamais été
aussi divisés il ya des fractures dans
tous les sens et cette réconciliation
n'a pas eu lieu je pense qu'il a souvent
même jeté de l'huile sur le feu parce
que lorsque comme lui on s'adresse tour
à tour des électorats à des publics
différents qu'à chaque fois on utilise
les mots qui plaisent health électorat
il ya un moment donné on entre en
contradiction avec soi même je prends un
exemple lorsqu'il reçoit les syndicats
de policiers pour leur dire qu'ils sont
les les plus forts et c'est ça qui va
faire un article 24 pour les protéger
mais qu'ensuite il choisit le média brut
pour les jeunes pour parler de violences
policières ou même de contrôle au faciès
évidemment vous avez ce qui devait se
produire il ya quelques jours d'ailleurs
d'anlyses
ces produits je crois aussi ailleurs en
france des policiers qui veulent
remettre leur démission qui sont en
colère on a beau leur promettre un
beauvau de la sécurité ça ne fonctionne
pas d'envoyer ses cette aptitude cas
monsieur macro à une forme de sincérité
qui monte les français contre une parole
qui est une parole de l'entre-deux ou en
tout cas de halle en même temps et là en
même temps ces deux voilà mais vous
voulez reconnaître quand même qu'il
s'est attaqué à un certain nombre de
problèmes structurels que vous aviez
d'ailleurs porter vous et françois
fillon dans la dernière campagne
présidentielle et que ces promesses
structurelles et bien il s'est un peu
retrouvée devant un mur la difficile à
franchir
alors vous avez raison je parlais des
deux engagements qu'il avait pris la
réconciliation qui n'a pas eu lieu
au contraire mais aussi la
transformation du pays des réformes
en réalité quelles sont les grandes
réformes qui ont abouti très peu il
suffit pas de modifier et de supprimer
partiellement l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes pour que ce soit une grande
réforme économique la réforme de la
retraite on l'attend toujours
et il ya des béances notamment sur la
lutte contre l'islamisme il aura fallu
attendre la cinquième année de son
quinquennat pour qu'ils envisagent et
qu'il fasse voter une loi la loi contre
le séparatisme
elle va venir à l'assemblée puis au
sénat au printemps prochain
quand vous voyez ensuite allé très
ambigu le désordre est partout en france
partout partout les black blocks font la
loi le week end
donc je pense qu'il aura beaucoup pêchu
et la dépense publique
avant même le coc vide avant la crise
sanitaire nous étions en début d'année
au dernier rang de 27 pays européens
avec la roumanie pour le déficit c'est à
dire que le pays est mal gérée les
français n'ont pas pour leur argent
on dit on est un des pays au monde qui
dépense le plus d'argent public avec
l'argent des français et pour autant
regarder sur la santé on est au
quatrième ou cinquième rang pour la
mortalité en europe ça veut pas dire que
la crise est bien gérée regardez pour
l'éducation nationale
il ya quelques jours on apprenait que
nous avions nos enfants avaient un des
plus mauvais niveau de maths etc ce
niveau était en train de chuter de
dégringoler alors que là encore on y met
beaucoup d'argent public donc notre
problème en france c'est un problème où
la dépense publique est est excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productif
les français n'ont pas pour leur argent
de ce point de vue emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande oui
oui alors je vais revenir sur la dépense
publique vous avez vous avez raison de
deux souligné il a quand même eu la
crise pandémique qui est toujours
aujourd'hui valorisation avec des
résultats quand on se compare aux pays
étrangers aux européens bas qui sont à
peu près équivalents quoi je ne le crois
pas je ne le crois pas je vous ai donné
ce qu'a révélé d'ailleurs une des deux
commissions d'enquêté il y avait deux
commission denquête qu'ovide assemblée
nationale et sénat le taux de mortalité
en france par rapport aux pays européens
nous classe au 4e ou 5e rang nous allons
arriver ce soir à plus de 60 mille morts
voilà c'est c'est excessif et ça veut
dire que nous ne sommes pas parmi les
meilleurs pays
quand vous prenez aussi le bruno
retailleau un responsable politique
comme vous qui est aux affaires depuis
pas mal de temps
est ce que pourrai pas est-ce que vous
ne pourriez pas avec vous vos confrères
reconnaître que la responsabilité
collective
elle est collective parce que l est de l
aide du fait de la totalité de la classe
politique qui est au pouvoir depuis 20
ans non on parle de la gestion du
commune dès le mois de mars vous savez
je suis un de ceux qui a permis aux
collectivités et aux entreprises privées
de commandes est par elle même les
masques
voilà parce que nous avons accumulée au
sénat le gouvernement a pas à prendre un
arrêté qui autorisait la liberté pour
les entreprises et les collectivités de
s'approvisionner
alors que le premier ministre de
l'époque le ministre de la santé de
l'époque nous promettait des centaines
de millions de masques commandés et les
masques n'arrivait pas ensuite il ya eu
les tests non j'ai toujours dit que on
nous sommes un des pays qui a été le
moins efficace pour le
contrôle de l'épidémie à chaque fois on
morigène les français on leur dit
attention il ya du relâchement regarder
pour l' isolement
l' isolement on sait que c'est ce qui
permet on vient d'avoir ce matin les
résultats d'une étude de l'institut
pasteur très intéressante qui concerne
25 mille malades positif au qu'ovide et
on s'aperçoit que les deux tiers ont été
contaminées chez eux c'est pour ça que
quand il ya un cas positif il faut lui
proposer
s'il ya une grande maison bien sûr il
peut peut-être ciselé chez lui mais
sinon on doit réquisitionner des hôtels
et isolés pendant une semaine les gens
les accompagner évidemment il faut dire
que la situation actuelle vous pouvez
pas là vous pouvez pas la critique et le
couvre feu la fermeture des stations de
ski
tout ça vous pouvez nous opposer à sion
il pas non mais je ne critique pas le
couvre-feu jeudi depuis le départ depuis
le départ et tout les comment diriger
déclarations que j'ai faites au sénat
sont enregistrés et c'est facile de s'y
référer
je dis depuis le départ que le
confinement
le couvre-feu n'a de sens que si
parallèlement on mène une offensive
résolu déterminée pour casser la chaîne
de l'épidémie
la chaîne de contagion comment est-ce
qu'on attend la casse ont la casse en
traçant c'est à dire il faut d'abord des
pistes et voilà et on n'a pas bien des
pistes et puisque vous savez que le
résultat des tests arrivé dix jours trop
tard et donc les gens qui étaient
positifs avaient eu le temps de
contaminer il faut donc aller voir quels
sont les super contaminateur et il faut
isoler les cas positifs parce que sinon
vous ne faites rien vous êtes dans la
politique de stop and go vous confiné
vous des confiné vous faites du
couvre-feu vous re confiné et advitam
eternam alors certes qui va y avoir la
vaccination
mais avant que une proportion
significative de la population française
soit immunisée il faudra des mois et des
mois donc il faut absolument mieux
contrôler l'épidémie
je crois que c'est vraiment le défi je
sais que c'est pas facile je ne dis pas
moi que il ya des évidences mais quand
même il ya des pays pas seulement en
asie mais aussi en europe je pense à des
pays du sud comme le portugal des pays
du nord comme l'allemagne ou l'autriche
ou ailleurs qui se débrouillent beaucoup
mieux que nous les frontières pourquoi
est-ce qu'on est un des seuls pays
un sénateur qui réside à berlin voilà
qui représente ce qu'on appelle les
français qui résident à l'étranger me
disais que dans le sens de berlin en
france ben voilà il n'y a pas de
problème on rentre en france comme ça
mais dans l'autre sens voilà il doit
faire un certain nombre
il doit prendre des précautions et il a
une petite quarantaine a observé donc on
voit bien que cette non fermeture des
frontières correspond à une forme
d'idéologie
selon laquelle les frontières doivent
être toujours ouverte or les pays qui
ont bien maîtriser l'épidémie
ce sont des pays qui ont fermé leurs
frontières au bon moment alors je vous
arrête on revient dans un quart de
seconde pour parler plus précisément des
solutions alternatives et surtout de
votre projet retour sur le plateau de la
grande interview avec notre invité bruno
retailleau le sénateur de vendée
président du groupe et l'air au sénat et
puis candidat à la présidentielle ou du
moins à la primaire de la présidentielle
qui le demandent que son groupe organise
ou non retailleau une présidentielle ben
c'est un discours une analyse critique
dont nous venons de parler un petit peu
mais c'est surtout un projet une
politique alternative à proposer aux
électeurs alors vous insistez beaucoup
sur l'aspect des dépenses publiques ou
la promesse du président mac ronde on
vous dit qu'elle n'a pas été tenues sur
cette gestion budgétaire trop de
dépenses c'est vrai mais les dépenses
ont soutenu l'activité
les dépenses en question que vous
critiquez correspondent à un effort
colossal qui a été fait pour soutenir
l'activité économique complètement
attaqué par par le confinement et
parlerait par le cos vide finalement
quel but vous avez raison jean marc
sylvestre je pense que quand il y à un
choc aussi important qui touche la
france mais qui touche l'europe qui
touche le monde entier le rôle de l'état
est d'être un bouclier c'est d'être un
amortisseur de crise parce que si on ne
soutient pas nos entreprises ces
entreprises feront faillite ce sera
d'ailleurs des recettes fiscales en
moins mais surtout ce sera des emplois
de la souffrance sociale
en plus donc je n'ai jamais discuté j'ai
fait d'ailleurs un papier dans un grand
journal économique le 11 mars avant même
que le gouvernement ait pris ces mesures
et les propositions que je faisais à
l'époque sur le chômage technique sur un
certain nombre de points ont été
reprises d'ailleurs par le gouvernement
donc ce n'est pas cela que je critique
ce que je critique c'est que on est dans
un état d'addiction de grande dépendance
à la dépense publique et que on est
arrivé à un moment donné où nous avons
la dépense publique qui dévorent les
efforts des des français on est un état
bureaucratique
écoutez comment se fait-il que on est un
des pays qui dépensent le plus pour sa
santé et au printemps dernier
nos soignants dans les hôpitaux de
se tailler dans les sacs poubelles des
sur blues c'est quand même incroyable
donc c'est ce que je dénonce et je ne
veux pas du sang et des larmes
je pense que le sens il est l'âme on les
a déjà je vous prendre un exemple je
crois que on a nos jeunes professeurs
certifiés ou agrégés sont très très mal
payé l'is on est en cours de leur
carrière payé à peu près 20% de moins
que la moyenne des pays de cdo il
suffirait qu'il travaille deux heures de
plus qu'ils soient rémunérés plus que ce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui on
revaloriserait leur carrière ont relevé
alors ''serait leurs salaires et ça
permet d'avoir une économie de 48 mille
emplois donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que dans un système qui est inefficace
plus vous à rajouter de l'argent - vous
obtenez de résultats c'est la même chose
pour l'hôpital oui je vous entends bien
trop de dépenses trop d'état est ce que
ça veut dire que quelque part vous avez
des projets de privatiser un certain
nombre d'activités qui sont aujourd'hui
asphyxiée par l'état je pense en tout
cas qu'il ya trop de bureaucratie
cette crise démocratiser trop d'état oui
c'est ça c'est à dire un état inefficace
je vais vous prendre un exemple bien
faire comprendre c'est l'hôpital
pourquoi est-ce-que pourquoi est ce que
en france l'encadrement dans nos
hôpitaux le personnel d'encadrement
administratif donc ses 34% en allemagne
c'est 24 ou 25 % 21 % au danemark
si nous avions le même taux
administratif dans nos hôpitaux par
exemple que l'allemagne on dégagerait
plus de cent mille emplois donc on voit
bien que la réforme de l'hôpital bien
sûr moi j'étais favorable à ce qu'on
revalorise par exemple les salaires mais
ça ne peut pas suffire
il faut donner plus de pouvoir aux
médecins et moins de pouvoirs aux
administrateurs il faut donner plus
d'autonomie aux hôpitaux
il faut sans doute régionaliser par
exemple les ars je pense que les régions
peuvent avoir leur mot à dire sur
l'offre de santé et on aura un état
beaucoup plus souple voyez trop de
dépenses beaucoup de dépenses dont la
plupart vous le dites on était opportune
compte tenu de la gravité de la
situation tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
que dira le candidat à la présidentielle
quand on lui demandera comment rambourg
cette dette parce que vous aurez ce
dossier sur votre bureau
voilà d'abord je pense qu'il faut pas
entretenir les français dans une sorte
de mensonges anesthésiant en indiquant
qu' on peut faire de la dette sans
problème l'argent actuellement elle
rapporte de l'argent bruno retailleau la
date elle a dû rapporter deux milliards
et demi 3 milliards c'est pas à vous qui
est repassé à bercy qui va me dire le
contraire
alors là où vous avez raison c'est que
on a un stock de dette qui est plus de
deux fois et demie plus important qu'en
2002 et pour autant le service de la
dette est resté à peu près au même
niveau pourquoi parce que les taux
d'intérêt c'est ce que vous entendez
sons sont très très bien vous avez
raison mais vous savez aussi
parfaitement vous qu'il y avait un
regard avisé sur l'économie qu'il suffit
très peu de choses pour que un jour les
taux d'intérêt s'envolent et alors là ce
sera extrêmement douloureux ça ce
contrat par milliards milliards et
milliards bien et la france sera ruiné
moi je pense que le problème est moins
la dette
en réalité que d'abord le trop haut
niveau de dépenses publiques
je vous en donne un autre exemple les
policiers à quoi ça sert d'avoir
toujours plus de gendarmes et de
policiers
si on a des tribunaux qui relâchent des
délinquants ça sert à rien il faut donc
avoir une réforme systémique et
notamment une vraie révolution pénale si
on veut soulager nos policiers et nos
gendarmes si on veut aussi surtout les
protéger et les encourager moi je pense
qu'on remboursera la dette par la
croissance donc il faut essayer de
libérer l'économie française et
notamment le travail les français en
réalité se sont appauvris par rapport à
beaucoup de nos partenaires les
allemands les suisses les belges les
autrichiens la réalité elle est là et le
sentiment français aujourd'hui cette
idée qu on est en plein des classements
dans une sorte de déclin elle vient de
là les français ont peur pas pour eux
mêmes mais pour l'avenir de leurs
enfants
vous parliez de la gestion de l'ordre
public
c'est aussi un problème de confiance
comment ramène la confiance on
s'aperçoit que le président de la
république n'y parvient pas le ministre
de l'intérieur qui est un de vos amis je
crois ne parvient pas non plus on rame
est vous avez raison tout est une
question
de confiance dans une société comme dans
l'économie d'ailleurs le caire
l'économie c'est la confiance pour
investir pour se projeter en avant et la
question l'angoissent française au
aujourd'hui est une vraie question de
conscience et on a un désordre
moi je les ai vécu j'ai toujours
considéré que la faute originelle des
mails macron j'étais président de région
le siège de l'hôtel de la région était à
nantes
c'est notre dame des landes quand on a
abandonné aux ultra violent notre dame
des landes quand malgré 200 décisions de
justice qui étaient favorables malgré un
référendum qui était favorable
les casseurs ont été récompensés on
adore n'est donné une sorte de permis de
casser moi ce que j'ai proposé
j'avais fait voter une première loi
contre les black blocks je propose de
vraies unité anti black bloc parce que
le problème aujourd'hui si on veut les
mettre en prison
on l'a bien vu il ya quelques jours il
ya eu cent quarante interpellations
garde à vue il y avait 105 qui était
majeure la plupart ont été relâchés soit
pas avec un rappel à la loi
moi je vois pas pourquoi on fait des
rappels à la loi la loi n'a pas être
rappelé l à être appliquée et puis il ya
les autres qui ont eu du nez en lieu et
il y en a eu quelques-uns qui feront
même pas de prison ils ont condamné
quelques mois de prison mais ça veut
dire qu'ils n'en feront pas mal je veux
des unités spécifiques poursuivre pour
infiltrer pour constituer des dossiers
judiciaires et pour permettre de
condamner très puissamment les black
blocks est ce qui m du désert je pense
qu'il faut une révolution pénale il faut
en en france le même principe que aux
pays bas un délit une infraction une
peine et une peine exécutée on a en
france 80 mille peines qui ne sont pas
exécutées il faut construire des prisons
bien sûr il faut construire des centres
de courtes peines pour donner des
sanctions d'emprisonnement de quelques
jours sans mélanger évidemment des
prisonniers dangereux avec ce qui aurait
des sanctions de quelques jours mais il
faut être intraitable et puis sans doute
changé notamment d'une carrière
magistrate pensez vous que pensez-vous
bruno retailleau de l'initiative d'un
certain nombre de vos collègues dans les
collectivités locales qui pensent
retirer ou supprimer certaines
allocations sociales ou prestations
sociales pour des familles dont les
enfants seraient délinquants et
continueront de délinquants moi j'ai
toujours été favorable par exemple à ce
que les familles dont les enfants ne
sont pas assidus à l'école ne touche
plus les allocations familiales les
allocations familiales
c'est aussi un droit mais chaque droit
en france doit être le miroir des
devoirs voilà je pense que c'est
important j'avais même proposé vous
savez que il ya une loi qui interdit la
burqa en france alors que
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de
récidivistes des récidivistes
quand il ya deux récidives voilà on les
prive de droits sociaux ça me paraît
tellement évident qu'on devrait le faire
bruno retailleau on a très peu de temps
mais il ya un poids un dossier qui fait
beaucoup débat actuellement c'est celui
de l'écologie
le débat entre l'économie et l'écologie
est ce que c'est compatible est ce que
ces continents surtout en période de
crise comme aujourd'hui
est ce que l'idée de faire un référendum
vous convient sur l'écologie et la
primauté et la protection du référendum
vous qui appartenez à un parti qui a
d'ailleurs il ya quelques années fait
passer dans la constitution un principe
de précaution déjà et je suis celui
d'ailleurs qui a fait passer à la suite
de la marée noire que mon département la
vendée avait subie dans les années 2000
le principe du préjudice écologique que
j'ai fait intégré dans le code civil
moi je suis favorable au référendum mais
s'il le président république veut son
référendum pourquoi pas je serais plutôt
tenté de dire chiche
s'il veut aller devant le peuple mais
attention politique la question la
question à man was et qu'elle ferait la
question à poser
c'est c'est rob immense la question est
posée s'il se dirige vers la révision de
l'article 1 de la constitution
ce serait de soumettre aux français la
phrase qu'il veut changer par exemple la
république garantit la préservation de
la biodiversité la préservation de
l'environnement et participe par exemple
à la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et le
français les français répondent par oui
ou par non
le problème si vous voulez on le voit
bien c'est que il veut utiliser
l'écologie et ce référendum pour masquer
le mauvais bilan écologique qu'il a
pourquoi est ce que le conseil d'état
pourquoi est ce que la cour de l'union
de justice de l'union de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne ont
condamné la france pour avoir dépassé
les seuils les normes de pollution
voilà pourquoi est ce que il a fallu
changer tant de fois de mr d'écologie je
vous rappelle qu'il ya eu 4 ministre de
l'écologie en quatre ans vous ne pouvez
pas construire une politique écologique
et du coup bien il en est réduit comme
il le fait souvent un coup de
communication
avec ce référendum voilà mais s'il veut
un référendum pourquoi pas qui s'exprime
devant le peuple
qu'est ce qui manque à ce pays bruno
retailleau pour terminer il manque quoi
une politique qui manque un chef
et est ce que ce chef existe sur la sur
le marché politique je pense qu'il
manque une vision il manque une vision
de la france il manque un esprit de
patriotisme voyez moi je suis toujours
blessé
quand j'entends le président de la
république parle lorsqu'il avait par
exemple il était candidat
mais parler de la décolonisation en dix
ans en parlant de crime contre
l'humanité pour la france pas quand je
l'entends dire qu' il faudrait voilà
faire un recensement de 300 ou 500
personnalités d'origine africaine
maghrébine pour les installer dans les
statuts dans les noms de nos places ou
de nauru ses parents c'est pas français
la tradition française c'est que quand
quelqu'un est méritant quand quelqu'un
est exemplaire c'est pas à cause de
cette couleur de peau peu importe voilà
alexandre dumas va là n'avaient pas là
bas aussi blanche que la mienne et bien
d'autres l'ancien président gaston
monnerville du sénat aussi donc voila
moi je pense qu'il faut une vision et je
crois qu'il faudra proposer aux français
un pacte ce pacte là il sera pour que
nous le peuple français nous puissions
reprendre le contrôle de notre destin et
de nos vies et je pense que la france a
est bourré de talent c'est une réserve
d'énergie il faut déverrouiller tout ça
il faut redonner la confiance
m intransigeant sur un certain nombre de
principes
bruno retailleau je suis obligé de vous
arrêter parce que l'émission tire à sa
fin maintenant il ya beaucoup
sujet dont il faudra parler et notamment
vous reviendrez pour l'après sur la
présidentielle le sujet sur
l'immigration je sais que ça vous tient
à coeur de sujets sur l'europe aussi
hein ça pose un vrai débat au sein de la
droite
merci encore bruno retailleau on
retrouve les missions en rediffusion sur
cette antenne
on la retrouve en replay on la retrouve
sur les réseaux sociaux et bien sûr sur
le site internet
rt france point tva très bientôt bonnes
fêtes à tous
malgré les conditions qui nous sont
imposés on va terminer cette année sans
doute détestable aurait il une des plus
noires de l'histoire en espérant bruno
retailleau que 2021
eh bien nous permettent de sortir de
cette galère a très vite en tous les cas
protégez vous et gardez le moral
[Musique]